let's just mention of course strictly
the grand final tomorrow night this has
been you know it's been great fabulous
down saying wonderful production values
all of that but there's candles well
probably no more than there usually is
what we've heard about more of it what
are you trying to tell us I think they
show always gravity I think we could
just so many people that watch it you
can't help but bring out something I
don't understand I mean so for instance
it next year next year if they're trying
to get a married person to compete in it
what tips would you give them to not
have something unfortunate happened why
does it happen why does why can't they
just understand this is dancing nothing
more nothing more than dancing I think
it's just an unusual thing for people
when they think somebody's being tactile
they're obviously coming on to them
we're actually that's our job as dancers
to be tactile and it's not unnormal for
us but people get the wrong idea so if
two dancers are together in the studio
it might not happen very close to some
when you're you know you as you say
you're being held by a lot of partnered
and maneuvers essential thing dancing
and so I suppose if it's really unusual
for somebody to be in that sort of
company or be that close to somebody
they take it the wrong way would you
ever do it Jason I think do dance don't
see what the stars
well I'm Hawaiian we invented the hula
so you know you've always done my mama
raised me she's like you can't dance you
can't
[Laughter]
your brother has solved the problem
[Applause]
[Laughter]
Darcy get out there
[Applause]
[Music]
you